de Jérôme Durin responsable du parti
socialiste dans le département il était
candidat sur la liste de Christophe
sirug écouter ses réactions
ce qui est une surprise c'est le
caractère très massif de cette victoire
de Gilles plattrelle qu'il faut saluer
ils ont fait une bonne campagne ils ont
gagné nous nous attendions pas avoir un
résultat aussi dur pour notre équipe
donc effectivement la surprise elle est
là il est évident que les résultats
départementaux ne sont pas bons pour la
gauche de toute façon il faut qu'on
entende le message des électeurs il y a
sans doute une partie de nationale très
importante il y a une vague nette et
puis il y a sans doute des éléments
locaux mais on prendra le temps de
l'analyse à froid tous les pas jouer il
y a un deuxième tour il y a des endroits
où nous sommes à la bagarre encore donc
moi j'appelle évidemment ce soir au
rassemblement de la gauche partout là où
c'est possible évidemment à lutter
contre l'extrême droite et le Front
National qui est bien trop haut à notre
goût et puis on va reconstruire c'est
peut-être le moment de de reconstruire
il faut qu'on entende ce message des
électeurs qui est très net